pendant de le taire une équipe de
médecins rend la vue un aveugle
grâce à une technique exceptionnelle
l'implantation d'une dent autrement dit
rien à voir avec la technique
traditionnelle des opérations de la
cornée londres etienne il est 3 heures
10 3h10 n'est ce pas être capable de
lire l'heure pour ce britannique de 61
ans cet acte là est un vrai miracle
malade depuis des années ayant déjà subi
trois opérations monsieur barça n'y
avait il ya quatre mois tenté le tout
pour le tout la technique utilisée et
c'est incroyable la dent du patient
comme un support après avoir greffé dans
son oeil gauche un morceau de peau les
médecins ont extrait l'une de ses dents
dans laquelle ils ont pratiqué un trou
de 4 mm de diamètre pour y placer la
landi artificielle la dent a été
transplanté dans la joue les tissus qui
se reconstituer et c'est ce nouveau
support qui a été greffé avec succès la
semaine dernière dans l'oeil de monsieur
bart scène il est à dire les cinq
premières lignes du tableau de test et
je marchais avec lui l'autre jour et
pour la première fois il faut les voir
nos visages
il pouvait distinguer par la fenêtre les
briques les échafaudages parce qu'il ya
des travaux dehors pouvoir se promener
lire et manger sans aide monsieur barça
ni en rêvait une cinquantaine de
personnes attendent en grand bretagne de
pouvoir à leur tour être opéré même si
les médecins aux prévenus tous leurs
patients qu'il ne recouvrirait que
partiellement la vue